Ashley, good afternoon.
Hi, how are you, Ira?
How are you?
It's Friday. I have like 5 service calls today.
Yeah, right?
I'm leaving after this call, so I'm ready. I'm leaving early today, so let's do it.
Wow.
Wow, you have any plans?
I'm just spending a little bit of time with family, so I'm trying to get out of here early so I can go meet up with them.
All right, I'll make this very quick for you. Hey, Andy, I can see you're here. How are you?
No worries.
Hello!
Good. What about you guys?
Good, good. It's Friday, so.
Hi, Akshay. I am from the customer experience team.
Pre.
Short introduction.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll just share my screen. Just give me a second. I'm preparing my deck here.
In time, it's not loading for some reason.
Problem.
I'll try again. Why is this happening today?
My PowerPoint is not working.
It's Friday.
Okay, I'll just share like this.
Okay.
There, can you see it?
Yep.
Perfect. All right, so thank you, Ashley and Andy, for joining our bi-weekly service call. Today, we're going to be reviewing the April 22nd to May 3rd performance for Raymond. Moving on to agenda items, that's all the same, no changes here.
Action tracker, I have two. So making sure, I'm making sure that RJ's submitting his weekly timesheet. I hope you see drastic change here, Ashley. Are you able to see that he's doing it weekly?
Yeah, I had a time sheets pending approval, so that was awesome.
Okay, perfect. And for the board review, I'm still doing this every Thursday and Friday. For performance analysis, the ITBD recommended KPIs are all the same. So you're already aware of this, Ashley, right? If you have questions for this one, if you want to discuss any items,
Uh-huh.
Any item here, you can let me know.
For the utilization trend, I can see here for the past two weeks, the average increased. So the average utilization for RJ was 80, 78 percent. So slightly below our target, that's 80 percent.
But then we're getting there. There was a deep from Saturday, April 22 to 26, but then I can see a big change here. So we did how to connect. I did reach out and talk to him about a strategy that we can add on, especially on weekends.
Plus, thank you for your help, Ashley, because you did give him projects to work on. So for the ticket closure trend, this is it. For the average resolution rate, we have 49%. We're still working. I can see that
Mhm.
the challenge he's facing was still during weekends because he can reach out to the partner, to the clients. But then, as you suggested, we need to reach out to clients Friday before moving on to the weekend so they can keep.
Mmh.
their PCs on, right? That's still in progress, but I'll make sure to let you know once we have progress. For the way forward, Ashley, we're still here making sure that we're fully committed to help you with the coverage, especially for after hours, and for helping you out for your daily ticket.
And that's it. For May 25th, that's Memorial Day, but then he's out that day. So that's not a problem for us. Ashley, do you have anything to discuss?
No, no, he was off. He was off. Was it Thursday this week? So like nothing new, 100% to bring up. I did see less tickets come through from the weekend, so it did look like some things were done.
Singh.
Yeah.
Okay.
There was a couple of tickets I had to reassign that he wasn't making progress over the weekend. They were getting missed for a couple weeks. And I'm not really sure about that, so I'll have to look a little deeper. It just came to my attention this morning, but I've been on back-to-back calls all morning. So there was just the one.
Yes.
Mhm.
Yeah.
But everything else looked like time sheets were getting submitted. When I was reviewing time sheets, I was seeing, you know, time entries, which was great.
So I was really happy with those pieces, just that we were getting a better output.
Mhm.
On the things, we're not 100% on.
everything. There was a couple. So for 2026, there were just a couple of days where I was a little bit unsure, but those are just going to take me to do the pieces. I mean, he's wrapping the way we need him to. He's accounting for all the time. So I will definitely take those as wins for us right now.
Okay, I'm glad I was able to help you out on this one. And for the ticket that you mentioned that's been pending for quite some time now, if you could share the ticket number as well so I can review it with him just to remove it from your bucket list.
Yes.
Yeah.
Sure, no problem. We got it wrapped up, so I will just kind of see. It's hard.
Okay, alright.
Mhm.
to just share the ticket with you because a lot of our automation is internal. So he'll have to kind of show you and then I could kind of explain how you see the ticket movement.
We can work together on it, no problem.
All right, but if you need any help, Ashley, I'm just always here. I'm available. You can let me know, okay?
Okay, perfect. As I go through it, I'll let you know if I need anything or what kind of specific coaching we could do to help resolve that piece. But I'll take a look at it first.
Alrighty.
Mhm.
Yellow.
Perfect, perfect. That would help me a lot. Anything else? How about you, Andy? Are you good? Any questions you have for us?
Just one suggestion from my side. If engineer is not working on a ticket which was assigned or over the weekend as Ashley mentioned, so there should be some internal notes that why that was not actioned on so that anybody doing the ticket knows that why it didn't move to the result status. And other than that, Ashley, just one question for you.
Mhm.
Is there anything else which you can suggest which can boost your experience with the ITBD?
Uh...
No, I mean, I think Ira's been doing a great job of like keeping me updated and communicated with, which is important when we run through issues. RJ kind of has some medical things happen that sometimes cause him to have some roadblocks. So communication is really important. But otherwise, I mean, she's been really great to work with. So.
I don't have any negative feedback right now.
Thank you, Ashley. Thank you for your support. Back to you, Ayra.
All right, that's about it. I appreciate the feedback, Ashley, and I hope you have a wonderful time with your family. Happy weekend. Bye-bye.
Thank you. Have a great weekend. Bye.
Happy weekend. Bye bye.